ANNE
Yes?
SHANNON
Hi! I have some bad news.
We lost your mom.
ANNE
What?
SHANNON
Sorry, that was terrible phrasing.
I meant we don't
know where she is.
ANNE
[Sigh]
SUNNYVALE WORKER
Ah, I think your sister's here.
JENNY
Annie, it's finally happened.
Oh my God. It's okay.
It's okay, I'm here!
We're orphans... Oh my God,
you're Orphan Annie! Oh my God!
ANNE
She's not dead! She ran away.
JENNY
That bitch.
KEN
Anne Yum! Your mom owes me 80 grand.
When you have it,
you'll get your dog back.
ANNE
I don't have any money.
JENNY
You could sell your eggs.
I mean, it's not like
you're using them.
ANNE
No! There has to be another way.
AUDIENCE
Can't stop the quiz!
TERRY
What is the square root of 196?
ANNE
14.
TERRY
Correct. How many hearts
does an octopus have?
- 3.
- Correct.
JENNY
What?
ANNE
Saffron. Saturn.
Aphrodite, Apollo, Ares.
Carbon dioxide. The equal sign.
[Bell dinging]
TERRY
Correct!
JENNY
Oh my God!
ANNE
What?
JENNY
You know this game.
This is how you're
going to make the money!
I'm taking you to the Quiz!
ANNE
Look out!
[Screaming]
MAN IN TRUCK
Learn how to drive!
JENNY
Racist!
Oh, hi!
JENNY
Come on! It's going to be fun!
I'm not sleeping on the floor.
ANNE
I'm not sleeping on the floor either.
JENNY
Then sleep on the chair!
ANNE
I don't want to sleep
in a sitting position!
JENNY
Oh my God.
♫ Hold up
About to catch another flight ♫
ANNE
I can't play on live TV
in front of millions of people.
RON
I'll let you get to it.
I know you gotta get
through hair and makeup.
ANNE
I already went through hair and makeup.
RON
Well, then you missed a spot.
♫ Ladies getting money
all around the world ♫
ANNE
I can't do this. Am I sweating?
JENNY
Yeah. You know what? Put your arms down.
You're having a panic attack.
Doctors prescribe these.
ANNE
Is that cocaine?
JENNY
[Laughing]
Stevia. Do you ever use stevia?
The sweetener? Yeah, yeah.
I've got it in my pocket.
♫ Yeah
'Cause girls is players too ♫
BEN FRANKLIN
Oh!
ANNE
Win or lose, we'll do it together.
[Screaming]
ANNE
That is definitely broken.
JENNY
I bet you I can pop it back in myself.
ANNE
No, I can't.
I'm going to throw up.
♫ Ladies getting money all around
the world 'cause girls is players too ♫
JENNY
How can I ever thank you?
Maybe, like, a drink later?
DOCTOR
Well I'm married... and gay.
JENNY
Why'd you have to say two reasons?